[Music]
sometime in the early 1750s a 22 year
old man named benjamin banneker sat
industriously carving cogs and gears out
of wood he pieced the parts together to
create the complex inner working of a
striking clock that would hopefully
chime every hour all he had to help him
was a pocket watch for inspiration and
his own calculations and yet his careful
engineering work striking clocks had
already been around for hundreds of
years but banneker's may have been the
first created in america and it drew
fascinated visitors from across the
country in a show of his brilliance the
clock continued to chime for the rest of
banneker's life born in 1731 to freed
slaves on a farm in baltimore maryland
from his earliest days the young
Banneker was obsessed with math and
science and his appetite for knowledge
only grew as he taught himself astronomy
mathematics engineering and the study of
the natural world as an adult he used
astronomy to accurately predict lunar
and solar events like the solar eclipse
of 1789 and even applied his
mathematical skills to land-use planning
these talents caught the eye of a local
Baltimore businessman Andrew Ellicott
who was also the surveyor General of the
United States
recognizing Banneker skills in 1791
Ellicott appointed him as an assistant
to work on a prestigious new project
planning the layout of the nation's
capital meanwhile Vanek returned his
brilliant mind to farming he used his
scientific expertise to pioneer new
agricultural methods on his family's
tobacco farm his fascination with the
natural world also led to a study on the
plague lifecycle of locusts
then in 1792 Banneker began publishing
almanacs these provided detailed annual
information on Moon and Sun cycles
weather forecasts and planting and title
timetables Banneker sent a handwritten
copy of his first Almanac to Virginia
Secretary of State Thomas Jefferson this
was a decade before Jefferson became
president Banneker included a letter
imploring Jefferson to embrace every
opportunity to eradicate that train of
absurd and false ideas and opinions that
caused prejudice against black people
Jefferson read the Almanac and wrote
back in praise of banneker's work static
Ruth correspondence with the future
president is now considered to be one of
the first documented examples of a civil
rights protest letter in America for the
rest of his life he fought for this
cause sharing his opposition to slavery
through his writings in 1806 at the age
of 75 panikker died after a lifetime of
study and activism on the day of his
funeral his house mysteriously burned
down and the majority of his life's work
including his striking cloth was
destroyed but still his legacy lives on
[Music]
you